/ photo juste réseau des faits religieux
et je dois surtout avoir une pensée
comme nous tous d'ailleurs pour tous les
français ou alliés qui sont morts
pendant la guerre de 14 18 il ya quand
même un million cinq cent mille soldats
qui ont été tués pendant cette guerre 14
c'est une guerre meurtrière pour les
civils
comme pour les militaires c'est
l'allemagne qui avait déclaré la france
la guerre et sont arrivés avec un nombre
incalculable de soldats comme il avait
pris l'alsace lorraine il rêvait une
chose l'arrivée après la france les
français ont eu beaucoup de courage
comme les alliés d'ailleurs ils ont fait
front le plus possible mais la marée
allemande était tellement forte ils ont
dû reculer reculer un peu à la fois
jusque au mois de mars 1918 à ce moment
là le maréchal foch a obtenu les pleins
pouvoirs pour gouverner
les armées alliées entièrement organisé
d'abord la défense et nous sommes passés
à l'attack à partir du mois de juillet
l'ennemi a reculé et ces messieurs ont
dû demander l'armistice
c'est à ce sujet là d'ailleurs que le
wagon du maréchal foch a reçu les pays
potentiels allemands et c'est là que le
travail s'est effectué messieurs il dit
que vous avez passé combien de temps
danse fagon nous sommes rentrés dans le
wagon le set
vers 20 heures senlis et nous sommes
sortis du wagon vers une heure de
l'après-midi le
est ce que tous les soldats étaient
volontaires pour faire rire non il ya eu
des volontaires bien entendu
quelques-uns tout le monde n'était pas
volontaire
nous sommes partis suivant l'ordre de la
mobilisation aux avions un carnet où
tout le monde n'est ce pas dans l'état
militaire nous étions et nous devions
partir en certains jours vous aviez quel
âge au moment de la déclaration de
guerre j'avais un peu plus de 16 ans
jeune et je n'étais donc pas
mobilisables
il a fallu que les clairons en ville le
9 octobre 1914 sonne et demande à tous
les hommes valides de 18 à 48 ans de
quitter la ville
pourquoi parce que les allemands est aux
portes de la ville et d'ailleurs le 10
octobre
il rentrait aux villes et tous ceux qui
étaient là étaient naturellement sous le
joug allemand
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez alors
c'est pourquoi moi je vais quitter la
ville et j'ai fait comme tant d'autres
j'ai suivi si vous voulez les hommes de
18 à 48 ont quitté la ville
j'ai suivi comme si j'avais cet âge là
et c'est là que j'ai eu pendant quatre
jours j'ai déambulé sur la sur les
routes la basse et fruges et cetera pour
rallier le port de calais nous sommes
partis là d'instinct je voulais à calais
je suis monté sur un bateau qui
s'appelait une nouvelle mais veut dire
que nous étions fiers de partir là non
parce que deux jours avant le mont
dirais-je l'amiral go home en bateau
exactement comme le nôtre avait été
torpillée en sortant du port et tout le
monde était mort voyez-vous la guerre
utiles ou inutiles
je trouve qu'on ne devrait plus avoir de
guerre dire qu'elle est utile ou inutile
c'est un peu difficile à juger puis
qu'on sait pas du tout quelles sont les
personnes qui vont vous attaquez
irrégulièrement si un pays est attaqué
il doit se défendre
nous sommes partis évidemment nous
ignorions complètement le
deux destinations du paquebot et nous
sommes partis jusque là rochelle c'est
ça vous êtes resté en charente combien
de temps là je suis resté en charente
300 alors là j'ai été ajourné une
première fois j'étais mobilise et
mobilise au 39e régiment d'infanterie à
rouen hockey l'année 2010 est pourquoi
tout fuit la guerre des tranchées
on a fait les tranchées parce qu'on
s'accrocher au sol de france et pour
s'accrocher
bah il fallait tenir par des tranchées
de manière à empêcher les ennemis de
passer n'est ce pas d'un village à
l'autre et aux beaux jours de colonel
commandant le 39e d'affronter m'a fait
appeler par un capitaine qui était avec
nous et très gentiment il m'a dit vous
allez partir immédiatement sur
versailles
dites moi vous étiez content vous de
partir pour versailles non je n'étais
pas content de partir pour ça et parce
que dans mon idée si je partais à
versailles
c'était pour aller soit dans les chars
d'assaut puisque il y avait les chars
d'assaut ou alors c'était pour partir à
salonique donc vous étiez depuis votre
arrivée à versailles en fait attacher à
l'état major du maréchal-foch toujours
affecté au poste de commandement du
maréchal alors vous avez suivi le match
et le fauchant campagne de mars à
novembre mars à novembre
et c'est comme cela que début novembre
18 novembre début novembre le maréchal a
demandé à grand champ et à moi même de
monter dans le train n'est ce pas qui
était le train du maréchal et nous
sommes partis là à l'aveuglette
évidemment porno mais lieu de
destination
c'était nous l'avons su après c'était
rotonde
alors voici l'emplacement exact du train
français 7 exhale trains français est
arrivé là le
le soir du 7 et les rideaux baissés nous
savions pas du tout où nous étions nous
avons vu le matin 8 au matin nous avons
vu vers 7 heures un train qui arrivait
de l'autre côté de l'autre voix sur
notre voie c'était que nous voyons là
bas la voix qui se trouve là bas et le
général weygand nous a dit c'est le
train des plénipotentiaires allemands
vous étiez à l'intérieur du train vous
avez vu les seulement arrivé j'ai vu les
allemands arrivent et ils arrivaient on
avait mis un caillebotis
parce que là c'était vraiment de la
gadoue c'était impraticable c'est par
cette porte que sont passés les
plénipotentiaires allemands
quand ils sont arrivés le 8 à 9 heures
du matin et à quel moment été prise la
photo que nous voyons là là cette
photo-là a été prise le 11 novembre vers
8 heures du matin il ya très peu de
photos du carrefour de l'armistice monde
des événements il n'y a qu'une photo
c'est la seule qui étaient prises
autorisées par le maréchal pourquoi est
infini l'armée qui tint sa faconde il
n'était pas question de signer
l'armistice ozone endroit connu des
allemands et même de la population parce
qu'on ne sait jamais ce qui serait
arrivé sur les personnalités qui
représentait l'allemagne
c'est donc derrière cette cloison que se
trouve la cuisine qui vous servait de
bureau
nous étions là nous étions un
cartographe et deux secrétaires dont un
excédent à lui et il ronchamp et/ou
travaillons de concert avec surtout le
commandant rien d'un g et le capitaine
daumier rit bien entendu le
général weygand à l'occasion des travaux
vous veniez nous voir pour nous apporter
des documents
dites moi vous avez failli faire une
grosse bêtise pendant les négociations
oui j'ai failli faire une bêtise énorme
jeu là vous j'étais dans mon petit
bureau là derrière et une conversation
et vues entre le général winter fed et
le général weygand c'était le 9 dans la
matinée le général winterfeld demander
même supplié le général weygand
d'intervenir auprès du maréchal foch et
surtout disait-il
si vous faites un traité de d'armistice
pareil c'est inévitablement la
population allemande réduit à la famine
moi j'ai agi parce que ma soeur je
venais d'apprendre par une lettre de
mado ma mère lui il est libéré le 18
octobre et ma mère dont les deux
premières lettres de ma vie dit que ma
soeur avait été enlevé en avril 1916 par
les allemands heureusement mes amis
m'ont attrapée et vos ceintures et
devenir à ce que je ne fasse pas d'
imbécillité depuis au cours tend de 11
novembre où je suis passé ici j'ai
compté au général weygand cette bêtise
que j'allais faire et il m'a dit en
effet suite était d'une gravité
exceptionnelle était à te dire qu'à ce
moment là une atteinte à un pays
potentiels c'était la guerre qui
continue et nous arrivons maintenant
dans la dernière partie du wagon
oui qui essaient de la table de
conférence la table de conférence
alors rentrée s'il vous plaît merci qui
étaient là et commence à ce que ça se
passait ces messieurs étaient chacun à
leur place vous saviez par exemple
d'ailleurs de ce qu'on vous montre les
places chacun d'abord de l'épée du
potentiel en grès et français libéral
avait mis sa jeunesse
le maréchal foch puis le général weygand
et ensuite ça le contre-amiral up de ce
côté là vous aviez les allemands avec
leurs officiers interprète nous notre
officier interprète le sous-lieutenant
la perche était de l'autre côté
messieurs quand vous étiez dans le wagon
avec ce qu'ils signaient l'armistice est
ce que cela vous rappelle un beau
souvenir
la nuit du 10 au 11 novembre vers 10
heures du soir
le maréchal son retour nous dit si la
dernière séance ils sont retournés il va
dans son wagon salon en passant dans
notre vestibule il fou lice la porte et
nous dit à nous n'est ce pas et pour les
petits pions sur l'échiquier le dis mes
petits amis vous devez très fatigué ça
fait trois jours et trois nuits vous ne
dormez pas mais c'est la dernière soirée
et je ne veux pas que le sang d'un
soldat soit versé inutilement après
l'heure le 11 au matin ils ont demandé à
être reçus très tôt puisque le texte de
l'armistice était formel il fallait pour
le bien qu'ils signent les pièces de du
traité d'armistice avant 5 heures du
matin afin que les hostilités cessent
officiellement sur tous les fronts à
partir de 11 heures du matin ils sont
donc arrivés à 2h30 du matin ils ont
regardé à nouveau toutes les conditions
les 34 conditions de l'armistice et ce
n'est que vers 5h10 que le général
weygand dit vouloir bien me donner la
feuille pour mettre les signatures de
sujets donc composer le texte de manière
à ce que il y ait deux paragraphes sur
le texte
plus les signatures comment les soldats
ont ainsi pu fêter l'armistice
ce sont les clairons deux régiments qui
ont sonné tous à la fois dans tout
partout partout partout sur tout le
front
le cessez le feu après la signature de
l'armistice était dire à 5 heures
creuses
le général weygand est venu dans notre
petit cagibi nous montrer à tous les
trois les signatures vous disant mes
petits amis vous êtes les premiers au
monde à voir les signatures sur un acte
semblable
soyons fiers étude de dire que nous
étions en effet très fier le train
allemand est parti le premier lui sur
une partie il était environ 10 heures 50
nous avons passé l'oise arroseur
exactement puisque nous voulions pas
partir avoue que l'armistice soit
véritablement effectif où son arrivée à
paris c'était le délire là la gare du
nord était noire de monde et j'ai été
porté à bras de femmes tellement c'était
du délire ce thème de la folie alors
vous étiez déjà très fatigué mais vous
allez encore passer une nuit blanche
non ça faut l'avouer franchement quelle
santé vous venu raconter cette histoire
je ressens vue mille émotions très très
grande parce que je revis instant vécu
auprès de mes vénérés chef le maréchal
foch et le général weygand j'ai passé
auprès auprès d'eux des heures
inoubliables et chaque fois que je ne
parle d'eux et chaque fois surtout que
je veux un retour que je vois le wagon
où je vois la statue du maréchal où
l'émotion est très grande et il m'arrive
quelquefois d'avoir mes larmes qui
coulent